ok e iniziamo a sto video con una
battuta intelligente un uomo entra in un
caffè splash tutti ragazzi femmine di
avessero video sono felice ed oggi siamo
tornati su apple con quanta passione per
happy with his lo sto dicendo madonna ci
stanno ci sono due livelli della stessa
persona che sono i primi alla madonna
chi cazzo è sto tizio l'uomo arcus
proviamo questo regala come primo è
bellissimo fermi come che non ho visto
sta cosa prima madonna il matrix che mi
sale fa chi sa benissimo sono morti si
nota che ci riprova forza bene ma è sono
bravo in sidorkin per carità di dio no
ma ci sarà una tattica regia impossibile
allora sentivo a meno che non faccia
tipo cosi quanto melo ci sono vivo fra
vivo
dite che mi ha schiacciato perché non ne
sono completamente sicuro è stato un
bellissimo per un giorno ma è giocata
una roba così [ __ ] 3d free svolto sempre
questo che deve lo stesso creatore
giusto per capire quanto è bravo sto
tizio a fare livelli superi g a sarebbe
quella delle cadute sono in 3d o ok ce
la posso fare ragazzi sono forte io aia
per chiedevo tipo ok perfetto
il trucco è quello di passare in mezzo
ok ho capito il trucco reja una volta
che capisci il trucco è fatta cuore o
perfetto best player in the world a
sucate
e ovvio che sono caduto come se fossi
caduto sul materasso non si è fatto un
cazzo vabbè però è bravissimo stati già
fatto altri livelli
ecco questo autore no giusto per capire
perché mi chi ha fatto dei livelli la
madonna saranno mica essere e quanta
roba fatto quest'uomo facciamo contro
peace corps ragazzi non ho mai fatto sta
roba di andare a cercare i livelli
perché li fa qualcuno c'è veramente non
è mai successo c'è il torcicollo è di no
perché ti vedo sofferente zio prove è un
altro figlio weston boltro fatto bene ha
fatto lo scoreboard ma veramente no non
ci credo mai un genio assoluto
ok perfetto vinto
madonna regala tanta roba impossibile
possible
ok finita la prossima volta a scrivere
un po meglio se hai voglia zio allora
milioni che si no vabbè ma quanto figo
aregama ma questo qua a vari livelli che
sono geniali posso fare di meglio ma
porca vacca e mappe faccia tanta sfiga
prova l'ultima volta ragazzi non so come
hai fatto veramente a non essere ammesso
ad oxford zio perché sei un genio
ok perfetto perfetto volevo questo io
ragazzi volevo questo va bene corsato
sta che voglio vedere una corsa a
ostacoli fatta da sto tizio ciò ho un po
paura effettivamente ci siamo ragazzi
tutti pronti bene è andata meglio del
previsto piano
ciao
eppure ai devo fare pure veloce vabbè ma
dai zio ben e velocissimo bravissimo
perfetto ce l'ho fatta la prima ce lo
devono superarne al 33 tutte difficili
ce l'ho fatta
come possibile dai veloce veloce l'arci
vedo il traguardo ci arrivo ci arrivò
senza niente senza mezzo di locomozione
frate ti giuro che non è possibile
fattelo dire ok piano più bravo zio
questo volevo perfetto e ora devo
superare lampione trabattoni culo sono
vivo ma non ci credo
staccati sacrati zio stack ho vinto ho
assolutamente vinto ragazzi sono
arrivato all'importante questo nessuno
ha detto niente in contrario
rob su in challenge ha addirittura
quanto mi devo pagare addosso su sta
roba fatemi capire presto destra ok
qualcosa mi dice che sono proprio in
grado di farlo siamo la madonna quanto
sono scarso dai ragazzi ce la posso fare
mi sembra impossibile ma cosa ho fatto
replay
[Applauso]
red cat quindi il rosso e la morte va
bene non devo toccare i rozzi quindi non
devo toccare io non ho capito era
intuibile quanto sono scarsa attenzione
non ci può stare fermi tutti che ci devo
dirmi che mi sembra incredibile quanta
violenza in soli una veramente
difficilissimo che copiano
ok credo per la prima volta nella mia
vita di aver visto il livello piu
difficile di happy with di sempre è
impossibile quanto difficile e
difficilissimo ragazzi poi è che ha
fatto bene quello che mi stupisce
in genere i livelli difficili di è più
vi sono fatti di merda e se non
difficile che sono in giocabili ma
questo mai fatto benissimo perfetto vai
vai ma si può finire
penso di sì minchia rega livello più
difficile ti stupro la nonna se devo
riuscire a saltare tipo ok allora faccio
ragazzo della sculacciata hanno piano
piano
quanti problemi zio fa e mi chiama può
essere mai così stupido se niente che
non ce la posso fare il livello della
storia questo mai vista la difficoltà
del genere sulle mappe perché sono vivo
sono vivo no sono rimasti incastrati
stimo va bene dati poi bello che ti
mettono la moneta all'inizio perché ti
devono far assaporare la vittoria che
non sa non ci arriverai mai nella vita
porca [ __ ] da marco che si chiama io
luca vecchiato ammazzo ti vengo a ceva è
anche senza così ossimo salta lo salta
lo so così così previsione è la madonna
mi ha [ __ ] bastardo perché loro sarà
la morte io sono andato sul rosso li
mortacci mia
[Musica]
ragazzi faccio un episodio su sto lì
l'ho toccato e non sono morto ma porta
con sé porta a porta sono morto bastanti
premio e va bene per l'amor di dio
finché non lo finisco non me ne va vi
giuro non me ne vado e il livello della
storia devo finirlo fatto pure questo
non ci credo oggi no no no no non di
lavoro no piano zio piano piano no non
tocca o ragazzi in un episodio di e
privi sono sono mai stato così tanto sul
livello mai è la prima volta che ci sto
così tanto perché è troppo difficile
ok ok bravissimo bravissimo dider è che
ci sei quanto sei stupido non ci credo
forza non ci credo ragazzo questo era il
livello più difficile che io abbia mai
fatto suo è più visto non ho mai fatto
una roba così difficile impossibile
tanto era votato anche un sacco perché
se non è nessuno l'ha finito sopravvivi
alla caduta dai facciamo qui ma dio mi
ama quanto aveva fatto questo ma c'è una
vita anch'io che ho fatto 505 55 episodi
di è più visto non è che ce l'abbia una
vita che succede oddio v6 minchiate la
visuale non vale spett
ecco questo è successo mi sono perso
qualcosa
ho trovato una testa ho trovato più era
meglio se non continuavo a guardare in
realtà prove madonna che testata se mi
servisse mai la testa di ricambio almeno
so dove prenderla scusa non volevo di
sorgere il tuo televisore incredibile a
2000 pollici full hd le
tre di loro ci sono caduto sopra è la
mia assicurazione copre i danni la
caduta da balcone vai tranquillo food
battle game
cosa vuol dire abbiamo lanciarci del c
bello lancio il cibo io datemi un
hamburger carenza di calorie bellissimo
devo fare cosa devo fare
scusa zio giuro non volevo errico
sibello bravissimo sono finito nel bu un
buco c'era è incrinò di centi ma i
bookie tu uomo di cento il solo quando
non devi vai vai vai mai togliti dalle
pene quanto sei brutto ma perché cavo
doveva andare più indietro e che ne so
io dio
ragazzi io non ce l'ho coi pretzel e ve
lo giuro nega però successo dato mi
hanno ucciso
come sono prezzo poiché non capisco cioè
non c'è stata armino lo jia americana di
dolci e cose credo sia un prezzo
comunque ok effetto muori perfetto fatta
a dovevo toccare il set di high ok sarà
ciccione perché avranno mangiato tutti
sti prezzo e che ne so il perche ragazzi
faccio l'ultimo livello giusto perché
voglio capire lo fai ti sto tizio
livelli quanto sono stati figli venti di
crisi moto grand prix offre questo come
l'ultimo livello ragazzi non so è
obbligato a caso però la scelta dell
ultimo livello è sempre importante no
vabbè geniale non ci ho mai pensato a
sta cosa not easy e mezzo accorto value
però c'è e va bene
ragazzi è veramente impossibile non è
difficile
e invece no sono arrivato sono arrivato
non ci credo
non è possibile quanto era fico livello
della storia ora sto tizio qua è un
genio quello che ha fatto sì livelli
veramente un genio bravissimo zaccardo
ragazzi
credo che l'episodio è stato figo perché
fa tutti i livelli suoi ma sono tutti i
figli super organizzati sia piaciuto con
quello che l'episodio madonna quanti
nervi chi mi sono saltati per il livello
incasinato vabbè lasciamo perdere
se mi è piaciuto questo documento è un
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
come di video totale descrizione
senatori city sia decimi diamo il
prossimo video dei ragazzi